UK Prime Minister Boris Johnson is now
out at the hospital after testing
positive for coronavirus just over two
weeks ago
Johnson delivered the following video
message after his release take a listen
good afternoon I have today left
hospital after a week in which the NHS
has saved my life no question it's hard
to find words to express my debt but
before I come to that I want to thank
everyone in the entire UK for the effort
and the sacrifice you have made and are
making when the Sun is out and the kids
are at home when the whole natural world
seems that it's loveliest and the
outdoors is so inviting I can only
imagine how tough it has been to follow
the rules on social distancing I thank
you but there's so many millions and
millions of people across this country
have been doing the right thing
millions going through the hardship of
self-isolation
faithfully patiently and with thought
and care for others as well as for
themselves I want you to know that this
Easter Sunday I do believe that your
efforts are worth it and our daily
proving their worth because although we
mourn everyday those who are taken from
us in such numbers and though the
struggle is by no means over we are now
making progress in this incredible
national battle against coronavirus
fight we never picked against an enemy
we still don't entirely understand we're
making progress in this national battle
because the British public formed a
human shield around this country's
greatest national asset our National
Health Service we understood and we
decided that if together we could keep
up NHS safe if we could stop our NHS
from being overwhelmed
then we could not be beaten and this
country would rise together and overcome
this challenge as we have overcome so
many challenges in the past in the last
seven days I have of course seen the
pressure that the NHS is under I've seen
the personal courage not just of the
doctors and nurses but of everyone the
cleaners the cooks the health care
workers of every description physios
radiographers pharmacists who've kept
coming to work kept putting themselves
in harm's way
kept risking this deadly virus it is
thanks to that courage that devotion
that duty and that love that our NHS has
been unbeatable I want to pay my own
thanks to the utterly brilliant doctors
leaders in their fields men and women
but several of them for some reason
called Nick who took some crucial
decisions a few days ago which I will be
grateful for the rest of my life I want
to thank the many nurses men and women
whose care has been so astonishing I'm
gonna forget some names so please
forgive me but I want to thank polling
and Shannon and Emily and angel and
Connie and Becky and Rachel and Nicky
and Anne and I hope they won't mind if I
mention in particular two nurses who
stood by my bedside for 48 hours when
things could have gone either way
there Jenny from New Zealand in the
Cargill on the South Island to be exact
and Luis from Portugal near Porto and
the reason in the end my body did start
to get enough oxygen was because for
every second of the night they were
watching and they were thinking and they
were caring and making the interventions
I needed so that is how I also know that
across this country
24 hours a day for every second of every
hour there are hundreds of thousands of
NHS staff who are acting with the same
care and thought and precision as Jenny
and Lewis that is why we will defeat
this coronavirus and defeated together
we will win because our NHS is the
beating heart of this country it is the
best of this country it is unconquerable
it is powered by love so thank you from
me from all of us to the NHS let's
remember to follow the rules on social
distancing stay at home protect our NHS
and save lives thank you and Happy
Easter
that was Boris Johnson with a message of
thanks just after being released from
the hospital he plans to recover at home
for a little while longer at the advice
of his doctors before returning to work